no
i will never go back and i left cuba
i've been there
12 13 times
and this just
put me off completely jillian white just
returned from varadero a little later
than originally planned white and her
friend traveled together the day before
they were supposed to return home white
tested positive for kova 19 on a pcr
test her friend did not
she was then taken to a quarantine hotel
in varadero where she met others in the
same situation it was awful so i was
very grateful for these people that we
could actually you know talk and
um you know share this messed up
experience with after two days everyone
was given the green light to go they
were told they were now negative we kind
of said okay so it's too late to get a
flight um
let's figure out what we're gonna do we
caught around several hotels
to look for rooms but white and the
seven others she had befriended were
unable to find accommodations in
varadero and had to stay in a
neighboring town this airbnb that was in
boca and it stopped eight and we're like
okay we're gonna
we're all gonna you know one last one
last night together and then
get out of here and never come back
missing their return flights home white
and the others had to buy one-way
tickets back to canada white's cousin
was eventually able to book one at a
hefty price
white arrived home on sunday night i
just yeah i feel really anxious and
just
yeah kind of just reliving like
is this even real life did this really
really happen the government of canada
issued a travel advisory against
non-essential travel to foreign
countries on december 15 2021. amber
friday global news halifax